good evening everyone I am David Cohen
the husband of Carla Cohen who with
Barbara Meade are co-owners of politics
and prose we are here to celebrate the
publication of Mark tush Nets new book a
court divided the rehnquist court and
the future of constitutional law what
could be more timely we all know that
there has not been a Supreme Court
vacancy since Justice Breyer was
appointed and confirmed how many years
ten or so a historic record in the US we
know that the Chief Justice is ailing
will there be other retirement swill the
Chief Justice be promoted from within
President Bush says he is a plain-spoken
man he should be taken at his word when
he says he wants his appointees to think
the way justices Scalia and Thomas do a
reminder tomorrow is that it's the
hundred and twenty third anniversary of
Franklin Roosevelt's birth his
appointment shaped the Supreme Court to
expand the Equal Protection Clause give
room to Congress to use the Interstate
Commerce Clause to deal with our
national problems and expanded the
protection of civil liberties with the
notable exception of placing
japanese-americans in prison camps
during World War two for which we as a
country have officially confessed error
was it what is at stake here is really
whether the president bush's influence
on the Supreme Court and the whole
federal court system appellate and
district judges will extend into the
2030s and beyond well his next
appointments follow the confirmation
debates of a Robert Bork and Justice
Thomas or follow the Clinton model of
appointing widely respected appointees
who also were acceptable to
conservatives such as Justice Ginsburg
and briar what are the responsibilities
of the Senate and its constitutional
duty to advise and President Bush's
first term over
two hundred federal judges were
confirmed that is a greater number than
were confirmed in the first terms of
presidents Reagan Bush the father and
Clinton beware of efforts to change the
rules when the Senate considers the next
round of appointees including the
Supreme Court mark tashna sheds light on
the rehnquist court using his skills as
a professor of constitutional law
Georgetown University historian skills
and narrative skills to help us
understand the trends legacy and what
the future holds on matters ranging from
the bill of rights to affirmative action
choice issues the Commerce Clause and
federalism he also was a clerk to
justice thurgood marshall and has a feel
for at least the atmosphere of the
Supreme Court as well the book is
accessible to non-lawyers and the stakes
involved are too great to be left to
lawyers alone for those of us who
cherish the New Deal and post New Deal
legacy are our fears justified Marcia
touch nuts book helps us understand the
stakes involved and adds enormously to
our understanding mark touching it thank
you I want to thank politics and prose
for hosting this event and for all I
thank all of you for coming out i
thought what I would do is describe
briefly what the argument of the book is
and and and some give some of the fifth
I can a flavor of the kinds of stories I
tell in it and then leave some time for
comments and questions particularly i
expect directed at the future of
constitutional law i'll say a little
about that now but obviously i'll be
happy to address particular questions so
so what happened how should we
understand the rehnquist court well as
the title indicates i regarded as a
court that's divided at not so much as
people treated or typically think
between liberals and conservatives
although
there was that division but the division
that really drove the court has driven
the court is a division within the group
of justices who were appointed by
Republican presidents I the I'm the the
on the liberal side I'll just mention
that this briefly Justice William
Brennan while he was on the court and
following him Justice John Paul Stevens
have kept the courts liberals reasonably
united by means of personal skills and
charm and and some strategic decisions
particularly I think by Justice Stevens
but basically the Liberals had to wait
around sitting there waiting for a
division the division among the
Republican appointees to manifest itself
so that they could take advantage of
those divisions as they did in important
cases so what is the division among the
Republican appointees well I described
it as a division between what I call
traditional Republicans and modern or
new d new breed Republicans the courts
traditional Republicans it's easiest to
understand them as perhaps the sole
remaining heirs to Northeastern or
Rockefeller republicanism the the
easiest example of that is Justice David
Souter who is a sort of classic
northeastern Republican justice Stevens
is similar from Illinois but from the
same sort of set a segment of the party
more interestingly i think the
traditional Republicans include Justice
Sandra Day O'Connor and to some extent
Justice Anthony Kennedy although both of
those are somewhat more problematic the
moderate Republicans were shaped in a
Republican Party that was transformed by
barry goldwater for whom William
Rehnquist was a speech writer and Ronald
Reagan and and of course modern
Republicans are Chief Justice Rehnquist
and justices Scalia and Thomas now
traditional and modern Republicans find
common ground on some issues in
particular in anus
in some degree of suspicion of the power
of large national bureaucracies which
may account for their unity in on the
issues that some journalists have
described as a federalism revolution
restricting the scope of national power
and in concern about the impact of
government regulatory programs on the
efficient operation of the nation's
businesses which come out in some cases
involving restrictions on the power of
state and local governments to regulate
property in the service of Environmental
Protection or smart growth and the like
so those are the areas where the
traditional and modern Republicans are
united and when they are united they
control the court and so you get these
kinds of decisions that I've described
that traditional and modern Republicans
divided over what are we that people
refer to as the social issues including
abortion gay rights and some aspects of
at least as I would characterize it a
religious symbolism as part of public
life and now the question is why is that
part of traditional republicanism that
is northeastern or Rockefeller
republicanism well I think the reason is
that that strand of the Republican Party
again it's not a strong one in electoral
politics anymore but it is represented
on the Supreme Court that strand
contained a strong strain of sort of
upper-class noblesse of leash which
manifests itself as toleration for the
foibles of those less able than the
elites to control themselves and and and
as hostility to the role of religion in
the public domain and in addition it's
probably worth noting that the
traditional Republicans carry forward a
tradition of Republican internationalism
in their willingness to incorporate
references to non-us law in Supreme
Court opinions now the difference is
between traditional and modern
republicanism may just explain why the
Republican appointees disagreed among
themselves and gave the liver
opportunities to pick up some victories
particularly in the social issue cases
but I obviously justice O'Connor and
Kennedy were appointed by Ronald Reagan
justice O'Connor was politically active
in the Arizona Republican Party when it
was already dominated by Barry Goldwater
and justice Kennedy was an important
lobbyist allied with Ronald Reagan in
California so something needs to be
claimed about why they take that role
that what I'm calling the traditional
Republican role on the Supreme Court and
and here I have some account of what the
reason is on the personal level for
justice O'Connor to begin I the
explanation I think is that her location
in Arizona was essentially an accident
after her husband completed his military
service she and her husband decided to
return to the Southwest where she had
been raised she had a small lot law
practice from which she would through
briefly when her children were born it
basically she was a typical suburban
Republican women although with a
professional degree in the 1950s and
1960s and like many such women she
became involved in a range of civic
activities many with a good government
and social responsibility cast and then
don't devoted her energies to Republican
activism except for the fact that she
was an activist in Arizona justice
O'Connor's biography would readily fit
her into the category of traditional
republicanism a 1-1 term for traditional
Republicans and sometimes uses Country
Club republicanism it's the
republicanism of the people who spend
their time at country clubs and justice
O'Connor fits into that category
reasonably well and even as a Republican
activist justice O'Connor found herself
the leader in a closely divided
legislature it actually was divided 5050
16 to 16 Arizona is a small state where
her success depended on her ability to
accommodate the views of the state's
Democrat now another reason for justice
O'Connor's traditional Republicans may
derive from her relations on the court
itself she was of course the fort's
first woman justice
and if you read the internal documents
from the period of her first few years
which are available in at the Library of
Congress you'll see that her new
colleagues initially found her a bit
stiff and hard to read and as with many
justices it took her several years to
settle into her new job just as she
became comfortable on the court Antonin
Scalia arrived and it seems reasonably
clear that justice O'Connor rather
quickly came to regard Justice Scalia
something of an intellectual bully she
expressed the opinion that Justice
Scalia was as she put it not a very
polite man and by casting her valuation
in terms of politeness that indicates
one of the ways in which he was indeed a
traditional Republican being polite
matters in that circle I seems to me
that that relations between justice
O'Connor and Scalia were permanently
soured in 1989 which is only three years
after Scalise arrival when Justice
Scalia was infuriated by justice
O'Connor's failure to indicate that from
the outset of the first time the court
had a chance to overturn Roe and Wade
that she wasn't going to join an opinion
that substantially undermined row as
Justice Scalia saw things her as I think
he saw dithering had had the effect of
leading to an opinion for the court that
was less anti row than it would have
been had everybody known from the outset
that she wasn't going to be on board and
and finally the addition of Justice Ruth
Bader Ginsburg and Stephen Breyer to the
court bolstered justice O'Connor in her
traditional republicanism I think the
former is simply by being another woman
on the court and therefore you know
somebody who had the same kinds of
background experiences and justice
breyer by providing a substantial
intellectual counter to Justice Scalia
one of the things that I say in the book
about Justice Scalia is that what's
happened to him on the court is
something like this
uh when he arrived on the court he
thought of himself as pretty clearly the
smartest kid on the block and and he may
have been I think that's arguable even
as of 1986 but as more justices join the
court he it's pretty clear that he's no
longer at the head of the pack if he
ever was he's sort of in the middle of
the court in intellectual smarts it's
actually quite talented court and
Justice Scalia is no longer at the the
smartest kid on the block and and so he
in some level can't get away with
internally get away with the kinds of
criticisms of others that he might have
been successful at earlier I would say a
little bit about Justice Kennedy because
his position is harder to describe and
and it may be misleading to call him a
traditional Republican at all it might
be that he represents the libertarian
strand within the Republican Party that
would certainly count for his
anti-regulatory positions his vigorous
stance in favor of broad free expression
rights and of course his position on gay
rights um I'm latter incidentally it's
probably worth observing that the
court's decision in the gay rights case
of a couple of years ago striking down
Texas is anti sodomy law that decision
may have come as a surprise to people
outside the court but everybody inside
the court knew that from the moment of
Kennedy's arrival he was looking for the
opportunity to do what he did in in
Lawrence and Texas that the gay rights
case the again the reason for that
undoubtedly comes from a combination of
personal experiences and this
libertarian streak the difficulty is
that Justice Kennedy is not a consistent
libertarian in indeed his opinions and
his extrajudicial statements indicate
that he has a genial but quite robust
trust in the good sense of the American
people and reconciling that trust with
his libertarian
to be quite difficult yeah in every case
he's got to ask himself how could such a
sensible people have done such a Liberty
restricting thing and and there's no
obvious answer that you can get to that
question and the result is a certain
hand wringing in Justice Kennedy's work
most notably in his concurring opinion
in the courts first decision striking
down a law restricting making it a
criminal offense to burn a flag as a
means of political protest where in his
opinion he simultaneously asserted his
personal responsibility for the decision
and then blamed the framers for forcing
him to invalidate the statutes so the
the effect of these internally
inconsistent impulses for Justice
Kennedy is to lead him to behave like a
traditional Republican even if he isn't
really one of them and he'll be
anti-regulatory but not too strenuously
expressing some nervousness about the
courts federalism revolution even as he
participates in it he'll be libertarian
within limits preserving the core
holding of row against Wade as he put it
in in the decision doing so in 1993 but
voting to uphold a restriction on
late-term abortions in a subsequent case
the interestingly the divisions within
the Supreme Court's Republicans produced
a divided Court that mirrored the
divided government elsewhere that is the
divided government that was occurring
down the block between Congress and the
presidency and and and that's sort of
it's it's interesting it sort of
confirms something that political
scientists observed which is that the
Supreme Court is never really going to
be substantially out of line with the
views of the nation's go governing
coalition oddly enough that seems to be
true even at a time when there was no
such coalition so then next question is
well what did the rehnquist cord do and
the final question which I think I'll
reserve for discussion afterwards is
what what's likely to happen next what
the rehnquist Court did was as I put it
in the book bring the court to a
threshold
where it faced a large number of open
doors in a range of areas doors that had
been shut for two or three generations
earlier since since the New Deal
transformation of constitutional law
among those doors are a substantive
possibility of a substantial restriction
on national power to regulate the
economy which would probably manifests
itself in the first instance in
decisions dealing with environmental
regulation and in particular the
Endangered Species Act that's sort of
the federalism revolution area another
the other major area where you can see
real possibilities for change is in the
area of the law regarding government
interactions with religions separation
of church and state if that's the
description you want to give of it the
court a couple of years ago approved the
distribution of vouchers to schools that
receive that are religiously affiliated
one can imagine the next step being
saying if you set up a voucher program
you have to include religiously
affiliated schools and then there's sort
of the footnote and that's true even if
they discriminate on otherwise
prohibited basis like religious
affiliation in who they hire and it's
even possible although this is much
farther down the line to construct an
argument that on the basis of what the
court has already done what the
rehnquist court made possible you can
construct an argument that if you run a
public school system you have to make
vouchers available to people who would
want to send their kids to private
schools but can't afford to but what the
courts done is open these doors it
hasn't stepped through them and that's
what's going to happen next or the court
the next court will decide whether it
wants to go through those doors or not
so that's the basic argument of the book
and now I'd be happy to talk to people
I'm
ready to interrupt you excuse me there
is a black Lexus that is parked in a way
that is blocking other cars from getting
out if anyone here has such a car please
go and move the carb there's a lot of
cards about five cars backed up there
are seats available if if people would
raise their hands if anybody wants to
sit down there are a lot of seats
available and you don't have to stand in
the back you're welcome to come up and
join us no I'm basically done sorry
Willa that's what mark thank you very
much we're really um giving us an
insightful look into the court setting
the stage for looking ahead and doing it
with some unconventional wisdom so thank
you very much and let's open it up for
questions there are microphones here
with c-span here the listening audience
the viewing audience can only hear the
question if you go to the microphone so
if you have questions or as Mark touch
that said comments please go to the
microphone and the fire away just yes
I'm a little bit puzzle about this
argument about using foreign law since
Americas Europe jr. really and most of
our law comes from all of our law come
from either Great Britain is on the
other European countries I first heard
about this when a congressman wanted to
introduce a bill to to keep the supreme
court from considering foreign law and
then I think like a couple of weeks ago
there was an argument about it i think
at american university maybe at George
Washington University we've always
looked at foreign law for civilized
standards of decency what is this all
about just a political ploy uh well it's
sort of puzzling to me as well one of
the things it for some for reasons that
I don't fully understand conservatives
have gotten extremely upset about the
possibility or the fact that some
justices have occasionally referred to
non US law not really as Authority but
as sort of indicating that the
is you know what we're doing is a
sensible thing to do it's I've been
there their account of why they're there
bothered by it is that it's sort of a if
you really rely on non-us law you're
giving up the Democratic self-governance
of the American people and it's an
infringement on sovereignty because
somebody else is deciding what your law
is the the the references to non-us law
in the decisions have been extremely
weak mostly they are oh and by the way
if you look over there this is what's
been happening there's one decision
where there's a little bit of authority
given to what's what happened in Europe
so what what conservatives say though I
also a note in response to the question
is they're perfectly happy to look at
old foreign law that is pre founding far
in law because the US Constitution was
based on British law in a certain way
it's just modern constitutional law that
modern non-us law that they don't like I
it'll be interesting to see what happens
over the next few years with these
references to non-us law there there
there's a case pending in the Supreme
Court now involving the implications of
a decision of the International Court of
Justice or the World Court for the
administration of the death penalty in
the United States I mean it's actually
directly relevant to the decision and
we'll get some indication of what the
justices think about non US lawmakers
and their effect on u.s. constitutional
law from what they do in that case but
mostly I i I've characterized this stuff
as a tempest in a teapot people
conservatives are upset about something
that it doesn't seem to be reasonable to
be upset about this Court has had a lot
of 54 and 63 splits additionally there
have been a lot of plurality decisions
instead of simple you know
jordys do you see that changing with the
appointment of a new justice or do you
believe it would take two or more and
what's your opinion on that yeah well
let me talk a little about what's likely
to happen with the next appointments
President Bush has made it clear that he
wants to if he has his way he would want
to appoint what I've been calling modern
or Reagan Goldwater Gingrich george w
bush republicans to the Supreme Court
and and when one such nominee would be
replacing another modern Republican then
there's not going to be very much change
in the court so for example to take the
obvious one I think everybody expects
the Chief Justice to retire at the end
of this court term if not before mostly
because of his age and illness well
President Bush will nominate a modern
Republican to replace a modern
Republican all that you're going to get
is a younger version of william
rehnquist and a younger and less
experienced version of William Rehnquist
which means that the it always takes a
Justice five years four or five years to
get comfortable with the job and and in
the first few years what that'll mean is
that this new appointee would would be
more rigid than Chief Justice Rehnquist
has been in recent years but it's not
going to be a big difference if one of
the traditional Republicans or one of
the Democratic nominees appointees
retires and President Bush is in a
position to nominate and get confirmed a
modern Republican then there would be a
dramatic difference on the court but
that's farther down the line we don't
know you know we don't know when that
will happen and we don't know what
President Bush's political circumstances
will be
II at the time this nomination occurs
whatever it is one of the things that
sort of in the background here is the
the failed nomination of Robert Bork by
Ronald Reagan it occurred at a time when
President Reagan was in a weakened
political position it wasn't just the
ability of Democrats to mobilize against
pork it was that President Reagan was
not in a powerful political position at
the time and so he couldn't pull it off
who knows what what the political
circumstances will be when President
Bush attempts to replace a traditional
Republican or a Democrat with a modern
Republican I have two questions if you
have time for to turn but you were
describing justice Stevens and I believe
Justice Ginsburg is being the more
liberal that justices would you consider
them to be liberals in the sense that
Justice Marshall and justice Brennan
were would you consider really kind of
moderate justices okay I you want to do
the second hour are you trying to clear
Justice Stevens against burger justice
Brennan Marshall how it's clear that
there that what what we I do it what the
press describes as liberals on the court
are not liberals in the Earl Warren
William Brennan Thurgood Marshall mold
that kind of liberalism is just not
present on the court anymore one reason
for that is that it's not really all
that president within the Democratic
Party anymore you can see this most
dramatically in the the disappearance of
that group's concern on issues of race
the issues of race that the Supreme
Court has considered are affirmative
action issues not desegregation they've
basically gotten out of the question of
supervising desegregation or
anti-discrimination law and and and so
it's just it's just not there
right now but again I want to stress
it's not there because that's where the
political system is as well and and you
can't expect the court to be very
different from what's going on
politically good my other question and
actually what year were you clerking for
Justice Marshall 72 73 ok so my other
question is do foresee possibility of
Justice Marshall and justice Brennan's
concurring opinion to Furman V Georgia
descending in Gregg V Georgia are
becoming law of the land 20 30 years
from now oh yeah those are the cases in
which the after initially invalidating
capital punishment because it was
administered in a freakish manner as the
court put it the court subsequently
upheld capital punishment under revised
statutes and those are the decisions
that upheld capital punishment 20 to 30
years is an eternity in the Supreme
Court's history and it just doesn't
there's no way of saying what will
happen what has happened in death
penalty cases is mostly a transformation
of the way the court or the kinds of
issues that the court considers for a
while they were considering sort of
broad scale challenges to the
administration of capital punishment
even if it were even it was
constitutional so could you set them
somebody's death for rape the court said
no they're sort of categorical
large-scale decisions there's one left
it's currently pending dealing with the
constitutionality of administering the
death penalty to people who were under I
guess it is 16 18 years old when they
committed their offenses but that's the
only categorical challenge that's left
what the court has been doing is
considering the sort of the fairness of
the procedures in particular cases and
although I don't have this
readily at hand my sense is that
actually in these particular eyes
challenges the capital defendants the
people sentenced to death actually do
reasonably well at the Supreme Court
they don't win in all the cases but the
proportion of death sentences struck
down in these individualized cases is
pretty hot since no one's asked yet and
I everybody wants to know um when
Rehnquist leaves do you think Bush will
bring someone else in his chief justice
or he'll go for Scalia or Thomas who are
already there uh what one thing that i
want to say initially is because
historical memories have discovered are
short there's no requirement that the
Chief Justice come from within the court
Rehnquist was promoted from Associate
Justice the three pre the three Chief
Justice's before him all came from
outside the court that I think the
numbers are sort of 50 50 over the you
over the entire course of US history so
there's no requirement that had come
from within the court technically as a
matter the the field is completely open
and the question then is political from
the president's point of view now you
know I'm not an advisor to the president
but i can say i think two things are
reasonably clear about the two internal
nominees I maybe i should say for
internal nominees just to talk about
Justice Kennedy in O'Conner they've
basically disqualified themselves by
their decisions in the gay rights case
for justice kennedy and flag-burning
case for justice kennedy and in the
affirmative action case for for justice
O'Connor and in reaffirming row and Wade
so they're not realistic candidates for
promotion I've read stories about you
know trying to cut a deal with justice
O'Connor I'll make you chief justice for
two years and then you'll retire if I
were the president
a lot of deal i would buy into because
there's no way of enforcing it but you
know who knows so that leaves Justice
Scalia and Justice Thomas with justice
these are these people are obviously he
rose to the conservative legal community
and promoting one of them would be a
real political plum to that community
with respect to Justice Scalia one of
the things that happens in Supreme Court
in Supreme Court nominations in
particular Chief Justice ships is that
the justices themselves way in you don't
see it happening but they communicate to
the president what they think about
about a prospective nominee now Chief
Justice Rehnquist has been tremendously
well liked by the justices mostly
because he's an extremely fair
administrator of the court and he's made
it an easy place to work that's not that
would not be true of Justice Scalia as
chief justice he's all he's expressed
discomfort with the way Rehnquist has
has run the court and and and he you
know he's a very affable guy but when he
gets down to business he you know he is
prickly he or has you know shoots his
porcupine spines I don't know what the
right metaphor would be but I and I
think that justices would let a
president bush know that they would not
think that that was an advisable
nomination with Justice Thomas and the
the issue is entirely external politics
it would be a tremendous it would set up
a tremendous battle by the Democrats in
the Senate it would revive the issues of
Thomas's first nomination and then the
question is does President Bush want to
buy that kind of fight
you know that's a purely political
question if it's if it's in the next few
months and he's as he might have to be
worrying about getting Democratic votes
for Social Security amendments and
privatization and that sort of stuff
wouldn't seem to me to make sense to
take on this other fight as well but you
know they're the politicians I'm not so
so I think if you look at the array of
possibilities it may it from my point of
view it makes more sense to look outside
the court for a nominee then inside the
court and then who it could be you know
it's just there's a slew of candidates
who've been mentioned all of whom were
reasonably plausible just to follow up
on that is it totally out of the
question it to avoid the political
confrontation they might nominate as
chief justice Stevens to see to justice
rubes into them Pope and then send up a
northern hatch simultaneously oh well yo
anything's possible this one of the
problems that now has now confronts
president bush is what I think of as the
David Souter problem David Souter was
nominated because the first president
bush was able to say to his conservative
constituency well this guy is okay even
though he's got no track record but you
can trust me on him John Sununu who was
a conservative described Souter as a
home run for conservatives well that
turned out not to be true and
conservatives now are extremely
suspicious about Stealth nominees or
about doing something that might seem
not responsive directly to their
concerns so I Stevens I think I is not
plausible at particular it's true he's
84 years old he is an extremely good
health for an 84 year old
man and you know he could be there
beyond bushes tenure and so yeah who
knows and Orrin Hatch is actually a
little old for a nominee it wouldn't
accomplish the political goals that you
know again I don't hey if I were don't
have any inside line on this but if I
were considering a senator I would
consider somebody like jon kyl who's you
know Attorney General of Arizona and has
credentials and is much younger than
orange cat orrin hatch hi thank you for
the nice talk what I was wondering about
was the the the the much stability of
this court that I believe everybody's
been on the bench for I believe at least
ten years now and I'm wondering what are
the advantages and advantages and
disadvantage of having such a stable
court especially if many of the members
will be on there for say you know 20 30
years as as may be possible and if it is
a problem what kind of measures do you
think should be considered by the
American people uh as as was mentioned
in the introduction this Court is
historically the longest serving group
of nine people in US history there is a
period when the court had seven members
and it was longer than this ten-year
period but this is the longest for a
group of nine justices ever now that has
some advantages the advantages are they
know each other nobody is a nobody is
you know in his or her first year
nobody's getting the sea legs of getting
accustomed to what the work is they've
settled in and and they you know they
can deal with you today they they know
who each other or the disadvantage is
they know who each other are that is
I've talked to recent law clerks from
chambers on I call it both sides of the
political spectrum or maybe centrist
chambers I doesn't really matter but
I've
talk to law clerks from from an array of
of chambers and they say that there is
from their point of view as young people
surprisingly little discussion of the
law on the court add the reason is
everybody knows what everybody else
thinks so there's no reason to discuss
it and and so so that's a disadvantage
you get less of the sort of productive
discussion than you might otherwise get
now even changing one person in that mix
can make a real difference just in the
sort of crudest sense people will start
lobbying you have stable arrays of
personal and political or judicial
relationships will become unstable when
there's even one change so this isn't
going to continue indefinitely and we'll
see what happens yes something new will
happen with a new appointee again there
is this two or three year breaking in
period so it's you shouldn't infer too
much from the first year or two but
eventually we'll have a sense of what's
going what this what the post Rehnquist
court actually looks like thank you
I'll ask you to more questions you
clerked the year after up Furman came
down as States began reinstating the
death penalty in the spring and summer
of 1973 to justice Marshall express
disappointment apprehension uh well I
actually the year I clerk the the death
penalty was still off the books so we
had no death cases thankfully surpassing
statues yeah in statement right Justice
Marshall liver no I don't I don't
remember him saying anything about it I
I should say that that my daughter
clerked for justice Souter four years
ago and she's very discreet about this
so I don't have you know i don't have
detailed anecdotes to report but but she
described the the practice in stays in
death penalty cases as the most
difficult and wrenching experiences on
the court for the law clerks who hadn't
done it before but also for the justices
my other question is uh your turn was
the term roe v wade was decided and was
the case where they decided the term
before and we argued with nine justices
or was it still up for air up rabs the
decision would be at the beginning of
the term there there was i don't know
how much to say about this but there was
no question the case was argued once the
year before i clerked and that it was
set for re argument because essentially
justice Blackmun had produced an opinion
that the other justices regarded the
other justices in the majority regarded
as incredibly weak I've reread it at the
time I thought it was week two I now
think it's not so bad but but there was
no question about how it was going to
come out after re argument the only
question was how the opinion would be
improved from the justices point of view
you mentioned that Justice Ginsburg is
one of the few remaining liberals on the
court if that's a fair term to use in
terms of theoretical interpretation of
the Constitution I was wondering to what
extent if any that interpretation
informs her decision in the Booker case
in her presence and the majority's on
both of the opinions issued or if that
was a aberration in her interpretational
background uh just just the reminder the
Booker case is the case decided we can
have for two weeks ago involving the
federal sentencing guidelines in which
Justice Ginsburg joined one majority
that said the sentencing guidelines were
unconstitutional because they took
certain decisions away from the jury
that had real effects on on on sentence
on sentences and then she joined
essentially the dissenters on that issue
for the question well what do you do
after that and what they did what the
the majority on the remedy said was well
these guidelines are no longer mandatory
but they are advisory I don't you know
it's a it's a I don't it's not an area I
know a lot about my guess is that the
best explanation is that there's this
combination of principle which is the
juries have to do be involved in the
sentencing and pragmatism that it would
be very there's no telling what would
happen if we said the remedy was judges
have complete discretion to sentence and
now it's up to Congress to say what to
do the from a sort of traditional
liberals point of view observing the way
criminal justice and sentencing policy
have been set by legislators you might
be very nervous about sending the issue
back to Congress getting much more
severe sentences than you would get
under the remedy the majority
order but I have this is a sort of 30
seconds of thinking analysis of it is
spoken about the break-in time of new
justices I'm wondering if in light of
that you can make some comments about
what it would mean to have a new Chief
Justice come in as against the elevation
of Scalia yeah oh I suppose the the
first thing to say is that as a formal
matter the Chief Justice has is not that
different from any of the other justices
they described the chief as the first
among equals the Chief Justice has the
thought the power the as I said he runs
the court he administers the internal
operations of the nine justices and he
does have the power to determine when
he's in the majority or she is in the
majority the Chief Justice can say say
you'll write the majority opinion Chief
Justice Rehnquist actually some some
people use the opinion assignment power
quite strategically justice Stevens when
he is in the majority has been extremely
careful in opinion assignments the Chief
Justice has not been Chief Justice
Rehnquist has not been strategic about
that mostly be eight for administrative
reasons so annunci a new Chief Justice
arriving at the court would not be very
different from the promotion of somebody
it from inside the court in terms of
getting used to the operations there
would be some additional as you put a
break-in period to learn how you run
what the court with the justice is
called the conference how you run the
meeting at which cases are discussed and
but but whoever is nominated is
had no significant experience as a judge
or as a high-powered lawyer and that
break-in period for the administrative
side of it would be I think relatively
short the break-in period for you know
the issues will be longer but that's
going to be true of you know of a
replacement for Scalia promoted to chief
justice just as it would be for somebody
from outside named as chief justice
assuming that Rehnquist is the first of
the nine current justices to retire and
you were advising Senate Democrats and
Bush sends up one of his
ultra-conservative what you call modern
Republicans would you advise the Senate
Democrats to hold their fire and go
along and really save their fire for the
next vacancy that comes up because it
might be a Democrat or a traditional
Republican or would you advise them to
go whole hog in opposing the first even
though it's a modern replaced modern
Republican replacing another modern
Republican yeah well again I have to say
I'm not a political advisor these are
observations of somebody who sort of
watches politics and knows about the
Supreme Court having said that it's
clear to me that if the nominees views
on row and Wade are known and are in
favor of overturning Rowan did you
incite that nomination period if it's
more ambiguous I they have some freedom
my my inclination would be to do what I
sort of think of as the John Ashcroft
strategy vote again
but don't make it a big deal by voting
against you sort of promising that you
will make it a big deal when you think
it matters if the rehnquist replacement
doesn't really matter as it wouldn't
even with respect to Rowan wait then
it's just you know I don't I was about
to say it's hard to fight these battles
more than once but you know who knows
you know if there's a you know again
Ronald Reagan was caught up in the
iran-contra scandal when and when when
Robert Bork was nominated yo so yo if
you fought Rehnquist now and something
happened the next time around to weaken
President Bush's political position you
might win this one and you might win the
next one so yeah that's what politicians
are for not me thank you hi you would
express some puzzlement about the
opposition to references to foreign law
in the work of the court would you be
similarly puzzled if there were
opposition to references to religious
law yeah well I was saying I wouldn't be
puzzled by the opposition because
there's a sort of pre-existing fairly
strong call it again constituency it's
not everybody in the country
constituency for you know would be
characterized as strict separation of
church and state and that looks like the
melding of church and state as an
analytic matter I'm not you know I'm not
sure it's outside the bounds but yeah
would there would be I wouldn't be
puzzled by opposition I'm interested in
your comments on the break-in period my
sense for the great many of the justices
in the past has been that they've gotten
more liberal as the facts of kind of
overwhelmed them and before they come
there they had ever never been
presented with these kinds of facts but
I think today you've got a much more
ideological bent I suppose that's who
you call new Republicans though you have
new you haven't used that term and my
guess is they won't change from the day
they get on the court uh not fierce in
your comment yeah well they're there
they're two things that go on one is
just having to think through how you do
law about issues that you haven't
confronted before you may have
ideological predispositions but you a
lot of things may not know exactly how
you play those out in a particular legal
controversy you may think for example
that displays of religious symbolism in
public are not such a bad thing but
articulating why that's so as a matter
of legal doctrine if you haven't thought
it through if you haven't worked with
this stuff will take some time now you
might not end up you might end up voting
to allow those displays anyway because
of your ideological predispositions but
it will take some work that's the kind
of thing I have in mind I should note
also that these comments from the law
clerks could also be explained as saying
look there are audio logs everywhere on
the court it's not just the
conservatives who are audio logs the
Liberals go on death penalty cases know
what their views are and its way in one
of these individual injustice cases the
Liberals are predisposed to find an
injustice and I'm told and okay so that
so it's I want to make it clear that the
sort of ideological rigidity that you
described isn't there's not a monopoly
of it on
side of the spectrum it's just that I
think we are all thinking about what's
likely to happen over the next four
years when the nominees are going to
come from a Republican president during
your term on the court the court decided
that obscenity laws could be determined
by the various states at various
communities you see that decision is the
beginning of a slow erosion of First
Amendment rights or do you think the
First Amendment is pretty solid at light
of the flag burning cases of the late
80s yeah one of the things about the
obscenity decisions is that they were a
complete failure from the point of view
of the chief justice Chief Justice
burger who was the moving force behind
them I mean he wanted to get this stuff
suppressed and and it's not I mean when
I teach this stuff in class I say it's
it's no longer true just because I've
done it so often I used to say it took
me 10 minutes on the internet to get
what Potter Stewart would have called
hardcore obscenity unfortunately the
site has now burned itself into my brain
so I can do it automatically but it's
just it's just stuff that even the
Liberals even potter stewart was saying
could be prohibited in 1973 is now
readily available and so so that issues
got away and then the question is about
the First Amendment more generally and
chapter I have on the First Amendment is
how conservatives have used the First
Amendment as part of the campaign
against what they call political
correctness and in support of protection
of commercial speech yeah it's quite
vigorous it's just doing things
different doing different things that he
used to do this will be our last
question yes since no one else seemed to
be up to ask one where are we headed on
the death penalty since we released
about 300 innocent people from jail in
the last 10 or 15 years and someone from
death row yeah I I think at the Supreme
Court level you'll fall I have no idea
what they're going to do in the pending
juvenile death penalty case I just have
no insight onto it I think you'll find
whatever they do in that
there's going to be continued flow of
what I've called these individual
injustice cases and just at the you know
to pick a number out of the air
two-thirds of them will win in the
Supreme Court that is the court will
overturn death penalties in two out of
the three and of every three individual
injustice cases it sees that's roughly
the statistics they've been running at
in and I suspect that will continue
thank you Mark tashna an enlightening
book that helps us understand the court
and the context for helping us
understand the importance of
relationships and the decisions of the
court for sharpening up the distinction
among the the two schools of Republicans
and we know that the this conversation
is not going to stop but is going to
continue thank you for getting us going
on it in an enlightening way mark touch
that will be here to sign books I'm sure
to have conversation and so please line
up over here and help us out with the
chairs as is the custom here by putting
them away thank you very much
if I were in the audience I would have
asked you here Scalia winners
personality growth on the Liberals
raises a question about professors on
the court below there's Riley Rutledge
is clearly a nice guy